foreign
so here's the thing I used to be able to
say cheap phones are getting good and
good phones are getting cheap because it
was true for a while there but then we
started getting these more and more
expensive Flagship phones they broke
through this thousand dollar price
barrier we've got super expensive phones
now so I can no longer stand by the
second half of that statement
but the first half
still pretty compelling and so this is
the Samsung Galaxy a54 which just came
out pretty recently and represents
roughly the middle-ish of Samsung's
lineup where they've got phones at every
price from like 160 bucks all the way up
to nearly two thousand dollars and this
one actually has a great case to be the
best value in the entire lineup I didn't
expect to say that but I'm saying it now
because I've been using this phone for
the past two weeks and it actually
delivers very well on a lot of the
premium smartphone experience but at
literally a third of the price of the
flagship from the same company literally
this phone MSRP is like 400 450 bucks
right now
you sign the right contract in the US
you can basically get it for free and
the flagship that I've been daily
driving for like the first half of this
year so far is the s23 ultra which
retails for twelve hundred dollars still
so what I wanted to find out and show
you in this video is how close does this
a54 get to this s23 Ultra or any of
these Mega flagships that are like it
because it's definitely not a third of
the functionality so I'm breaking this
down into five categories because these
are my five pillars of a great
smartphone build quality display
performance camera and battery so I've
said before if a smartphone can nail all
five of these things then it's a good
phone period And as a product goes down
in price then you naturally expect it to
start to make some sacrifices in some of
these areas so right from the top with
build quality it gets interesting
because Samsung kind of adopted this
thing where they use essentially the
same design language across their entire
lineup to keep it consistent and
recognizable by but that also basically
means that this 1200 phone does not look
dramatically different from this 400 to
450 phone Samsung is one of these
companies that only does the satin slash
matte finish on the backs of their most
premium phones and so the squared off
rails on the s23 ultra are a polished
aluminum for contrast the a54 on the
other hand is the other way around it's
glossy glass on the back and it's a more
Satin finish on the aluminum rails and I
kind of like that too at the end of the
day though they're literally both glass
and aluminum and so really it comes down
to two main differences between the two
one is the size they only come in these
sizes and so this a54 is definitively
smaller and lighter than the ultra and
two it's flat and that's totally fine
where the ultra does have this little
bit of a curve on the sides of the
display but to be honest yeah build
quality is very close here it is IP67
versus ip68 which by definition is
almost the same thing and the a54 puts
the SIM card slot plus a expandable
storage at the top where the flagship
just has a SIM card tray at the bottom
with no expandable storage if I can
safely assume that both Gorilla Glass 5
and Gorilla Glass vectus 2 both scratch
at a level six with deeper grooves at a
level seven I feel pretty comfortable
saying that the a54 is 90 of the build
quality of the flagship which is a
really good start
so then there's the displays now this is
Samsung we're talking about here so they
definitely go the extra mile with the
flagship display no question about that
it is ridiculously good incredibly
bright super sharp responsive adaptive
and efficient I mean every number on
paper is pretty close to maxed out from
the 1440p resolution to the 1750 nits of
brightness from an AMOLED panel 120
hertz Max refresh rate but variable down
to one Hertz with ltpo I mean it's
pretty awesome so the a54 display is a
step down on paper sure and when you
actually use it you realize that they've
cut out like the extra bells and
whistles the over-the-top stuff that are
maybe a little more for The Fringe
situations but still keep the screen to
a pretty premium level for 99 of use
cases so like I said this only comes in
one size so it's a little smaller in the
flagship but that's also probably a good
thing for some people because phones are
huge so this is a 6.4 inch 1080p flat
AMOLED this is still over 400 pixels per
inch so even though it can't do Quad HD
it's still going to be pretty great for
most people that aren't pixel peeping
like I am and it's still plenty bright I
mean I'm looking at this thing it gets
up to a thousand nits and regularly goes
outdoors and looks totally fine like in
the dashboard of my car and out in the
sun no problems so in that way it's
pretty close but you can also see the
bezels all the way around are a little
bit thicker this is one of those things
that tends to get like pointed out in
YouTube comments more than by people
actually buying the phone but yeah it's
true it does have slightly bigger bezels
and a bigger chin it's not completely
corner to corner and then while the s23
ultra has the ltpo that can adapt all
the way from 120 hertz down to 1 Hertz
when it's not moving this a54 display
can adapt from 120 hertz down to 60
hertz and basically switch back and
forth so not quite as adaptive and
efficient but better than nothing and it
goes pretty blue off axis more than some
of the more premium Samsung panels
already do and also that hole punch cut
out as I pointed out before is not quite
the little perfect black circle but it
does have this little shiny metal ring
that can be slightly distracting when
the Sun hits it at just the right angle
it's a small thing but I gotta mention
it but yeah they still give you every
single setting in here as the more
expensive phone to dial in the display's
colors and match what you're looking for
so overall I'm willing to say the a54
has 80 of the display of the flagship
it's obviously not going to match it on
paper and in the most bleeding edge
extreme situations like direct outdoor
sunlight and things like that then you
can see the difference but honestly most
of the time when you're just using the
phone especially indoors
they look very similar which is pretty
amazing just with slightly thicker
bezels so then there's performance
now this is where you start to get a
little bit of a wider Gap here so you've
already heard about the flagship
Snapdragon 8 Gen 2
8 gigs of RAM one terabyte of storage
all that good stuff uh this is working
with a lesser chipset here so it's it's
just not going to be as good so the a54
is powered by an exynos 1380 chip which
benchmarks about 50 to 80 percent lower
than the Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 in CPU it's
it's a very comfortably mid-range chip
I'll put it that way for context it's
putting up similar geekbench scores to
the a12 bionic which was in the iPhone
10s in 2018. so pair this with six gigs
of RAM and you've got a phone that you
know can handle everyday tasks but it
isn't blowing anything out the water in
terms of performance and the specs are
only part of performance like when I
when I say performance as a pillar
obviously you want it to be able to open
apps very quickly and be smooth and
reliable so for normal daily things like
checking email or social media scrolling
or just subscribing to this YouTube
channel like it feels just like the
flagships because it's fine and it's
also 120 hertz and it's smooth that
stuff doesn't require a super high-end
chip now sure there are few dropped
frames here and there and it does feel a
little bit different and if you gave me
these two phones and didn't tell me
which was which sooner or later I could
tell you which one was a lower end chip
but it would require me starting to push
you know some higher end stuff starting
to multitask starting to flip between a
couple heavier apps at once opening and
closing a few things when you get to
like navigating while streaming music
over bluetooth you know while reading
something in a web browser on a big
website stuff like that then the
difference is actually really quite
noticeable and then the s23 line all has
these like Lightning Fast ultrasonic
fingerprint sensors while the a54 does
have an optical sensor which is just a
bit slower and has to shine a light for
a second instead of the ultrasonic ones
which are more versatile you could also
argue that built-in storage is going to
be faster than expandable although some
people just don't care like they just
want expandable storage in which case
that's actually a benefit for the a54
but yeah it's it's pretty clear that the
performance difference between Flagship
chipset and mid-ranger is pretty big
it's noticeable it's a it's a feel thing
it's a smoothness thing if you haven't
used a more expensive phone you might
not even notice but that's what it comes
down to and especially with the higher
end tasks
these phones are running the same
software one UI 5.1 but just one
executes the same stuff a little more
reliably and smoother so I'm going to
give a54
60 of the performance of the flagship
not bad so now cameras cameras cameras
cameras we got all kinds of cameras
typically cameras are what separate the
good phones from the great phones
and that's still true so you look at the
back of the a54 and it looks just like
all the rest of the s23 series obviously
not as many cameras as the ultra but
when you actually hear that this is the
50 megapixel main camera and this is the
12 megapixel Ultra wide and this is a 5
megapixel macro
now you're starting to see where they
saved money like in what world do you
want a macro camera over a zoom camera
this is the obvious version of like
making it look like the more expensive
phone but saving some money not putting
a zoom but still having something there
so now the actual photo and video taking
experience is the same as the more
expensive phones literally it's the same
app the same UI the same features and
buttons so that's fine we can all say
what we want about Samsung's layouts but
you know they work they're pretty
straightforward and then the photos you
get in good lighting they seem perfectly
fine like if you don't compare it to
something super expensive these are all
super passable sharp detailed normal
looking photos maybe a little bit blue
with the white balance a little bit
Overexposed but honestly short of the
pixel 6A this is about as good as you'd
expect from a 450 phone but of course
like I said my goal is to compare it to
the super expensive big brothers so when
you do that highlights a little more
some of the flaws of the a54's main
camera which really is just that it
tends to overexpose and take
unnecessarily bright shots quite often
and the white balance is a little
inconsistent but it's funny there's
always this angle always feels weird
because most people buying this phone
have never they have they haven't come
from a 1200 phone they don't know what a
1200 phones
capabilities would be so it's like
comparing a Toyota Corolla to a Supra
sure they come from the same company but
like people buying the Corolla weren't
cross shopping with a Supra and they
weren't even thinking about getting a
performance of a Supra so just me
putting them side by side helps
highlight the differences uh but yeah
this camera's set is
fine I think sometimes I boil the camera
all the way down to like yeah this one's
just fine but I really mean it it's fine
like when you zoom in yeah you lose
sharpness because you went with a macro
over a telephoto so it doesn't come
close to touching the zoom performance
of the more expensive phone passed about
four or five x the a54 also can't do 8K
video or even 4K 60 like the flagship
can but it can do everything else just
fine and the ultra wide is pretty soft
as expected especially in lower light
but it happens to actually be a tiny bit
wider than the flagship's ultra wide so
it's got that going for it you know
between the missing telephotos and the
Lesser compute power
this one can go in a bunch of different
directions but I'll say the a54 is 70 of
the camera for most normal photos of the
flagship
which is
pretty good but then last but not least
battery this one's pretty simple five
thousand milliamp hours 5000 milliamp
hours and so it turns out the usable
daily battery life of these two phones
is pretty similar but
the thing about the chips though is the
the Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 which is in a lot
of the higher end newer phones now is
it's really good it's it's also it's
both more powerful and more efficient uh
than the XML so basically this flagship
phone is capable of way more it's
capable of a much higher Peak output and
so you can actually Spike the usage a
lot and like run down the battery pretty
hard if you wanted to but then it's also
more efficient so for you know combining
it with this ltpo display just using it
every day regular scrolling social media
email hanging out you know this is It's
Sip and Battery it's actually going
slower through battery than the a54 so
the a54 is more of a constant drain it
doesn't Spike as high but it doesn't
have as good standby time so the the
curve of the flagship phone might look
more like spiky but the a54 looks more
like an even descent if that makes sense
now you also do not get wireless char
charging with the a54 despite the glass
back that's one of those features that
you sometimes see in phones at this
price but it's definitely a common
emission and the max charging rate is 25
watts which is straight up slow in 2023
but it's fine it's serviceable there are
all kinds of phones offering blazing
fast like 50 80 100 plus watt charging
even at this lower price point so even
if the battery isn't amazing you could
at least top up quickly if you had that
but that's not here either so it'll take
about an hour to charge from zero to 100
totally average but overall it's it's
not a substantial weakness especially
versus the flagship from the same
company which only does 45 Watts so
a54 battery experience is is like 90 of
the flagship so if you total up all of
my assessments uh and average them out
over 500 points you get 78 of the
flagship for a third of the price which
that seems like it's pretty clear that
it's a pretty good deal now there's also
of course lots of little things that
didn't quite fit into those pillars like
the slightly better haptics of the
flagship for example you might be really
into that or the bigger speakers that
come from having a bigger phone that do
sound better uh also there's a stylus
in the big one uh also if you want decks
you'd have to pay up because the a54
doesn't have that funny thing is they
both have the exact same unboxing
experience which is just the phone no
charger but yeah these mid-rangers today
masterfully mitigate the law of
diminishing returns
matching the flagship's Finesse for a
fraction of the funds
thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one peace
[Music]